[Music]
on this Sunday night tragedy strikes a
popular Festival burning man takes a
deadly turn as severe weather converts
the desert into a mud pit stranding
thousands of revelers a lot of people
have run out of food and water what
they're being urged to do
a typhoon tears through Taiwan
the violent wind torrential rain and
where the storms barreling Now new
provincial policies on preferred
pronouns the fears they could jeopardize
students safety and Canadian men can
jump the hoop dreams coming true for the
national men's basketball team
global national with foreign
good evening and thanks for joining us
what was supposed to be a nine-day event
full of self-expression and art has
turned into a nightmare in Nevada tens
of thousands of people at the Burning
Man festival are stranded tonight after
two to three months worth of rain fell
in just 24 hours swamping what's
normally a desert Redmond Shannon
explains what campers are being told to
do and how they're coping
Burning Man normally takes place under
the burning Nevada Sun oh
this year torrential rain over the past
two days has turned it into a swamp
police say one person has died although
the circumstances are unclear they are
also telling the tens of thousands of
Festival Gores to stay put and to not
try to drive through the mud I heard the
Rangers if they catch you will stop uh
you from driving on it because it just
makes matters worse at times organizers
are asking everyone to conserve water
and food too we might be here until
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday next week it
just depends and we don't even know a
lot of people have run out of food and
water and some people are stealing
things because that's what happens when
things get weird there's a little bit of
this like Lord of the Flies Vibe however
it appears most Festival goars are
embracing burning man's ethos of
community and self-reliance the event
has taken place in Nevada's BlackRock
desert since 1990.
really nice people that are sharing what
they have
um art camp brings out supplies uh and
we have kind of a makeshift kitchen
where we prepare two meals a day some
have made it out including us DJ Diplo
and Comedian Chris Rock everything is
left behind but they're nice I have my
boots that's all I have right now Las
Vegas man money KES also managed to get
out on Saturday despite local officials
urging people to shelter in place I
understand it's federal land they can
stop you mentoring but legally they
cannot stop you from leaving with more
rain on Sunday it's unclear if many more
people will be able to get out once the
festival wraps on Monday Redmond Shannon
Global News and still in Nevada
thunderstorms have swapped Sin City with
heavy rain and flooding cars drove
through roads that looked more like
Rivers even the famous Las Vegas strip
was flooded one person has died
officials believe the person drowned the
storm has moved on and sunny dry weather
is in the forecast
a typhoon is set to crash into
Southeastern China and Hong Kong leaving
more than 130 million people on alert
tonight the powerful storm has already
hammered Taiwan as Mackenzie gray
explains it's the biggest storm to hit
that Island since 2019.
barreling into Taiwan typhoon hikeway
leaving a trail of Destruction more than
40 people injured and nearly 120 000
without power as the storm lashed the
eastern part of the island
flights and trains were canceled with
planes in Taipei needed to be tied down
to avoid being blown away by the 155
kilometer per hour winds
the Taiwanese president urging people to
stay home to avoid the worst storm to
hit the island in four years
the weather should improve in two days
allowing the focus to shift to cleaning
up
[Applause]
the situation many in Florida are in
right now after Hurricane Adalia slammed
the state last week it was really windy
and the water got really high but I mean
it wasn't terrible I lost power and
water but still here the extensive
damage ruining many homes and businesses
leaving some Unsure how they'll rebuild
there's no no flood insurance on any of
these low-lying buildings so only
anything caused damage by water they
won't cover a situation many others will
likely face in the future as increased
ocean temperatures from climate change
will allow for stronger storms I think
what we're starting to see is another
clear climate signal is the the
frequency in which storms can undergo
rapid intensification Adelia has now
moved back out over water joining a
tropical traffic jam in the central
Atlantic Ocean where there are now four
named storms with the potential to cause
more damage but right now nithu none are
forecasted to hit Canada or the U.S all
right Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mackenzie
stormy weather is being embraced in Hay
River Northwest Territories where steady
rainfall is keeping a nearby Wildfire at
Bay favorable winds and lower
temperatures are also helping but the
fire is still raging just a half
kilometer away from the town emergency
crews managed to keep the fire from
reaching the only Highway into the
community about 463 thousand hectares of
land have been scorched so far
climate activists have long urged large
corporations to prioritize being green
over greed now environmentalists are
increasingly taking aim at the people
leading those companies and what they do
outside of the office and gaviola
explains the enormous effect the ultra
wealthy has on the planet and what
critics are calling for
environmental activists have long had
big corporations in their crosshairs but
increasingly they're targeting the one
percent I do think the ultra wealthy
Lifestyles and the amount of carbon they
burn is over the top and irresponsible
and acceptable private jets and super
Yachts symbols of the unsustainable
Lifestyles of the Rich and Famous the
backlash comes with growing evidence
that billionaires are bad for the planet
fueling frustration that although the
pandemic Delta major Financial blow to
the lowest income households the rich
got richer of the 57 trillion dollars in
New Wealth generated since the pandemic
35 trillion or about two-thirds has been
accumulated by the world's richest one
percent and the 125 richest billionaires
each emit more than a million times more
carbon than the average person in the
bottom 90 percent according to research
by Oxfam wealthier countries and
individuals have a greater ability to
Shield themselves from or deal with the
devastation of climate change a luxury
developing nations and marginalized
communities can't afford case in point
last year's historic flooding in
Pakistan hit children and women in the
poorest regions the hardest women who
are fleeing the flooding in Pakistan
which was linked to The Climate
emergency LED to a crisis in maternal
care environmentalists are advocating
for a higher price on pollution as well
as a global wealth tax
we also call for attacks or an outright
ban on the planet wrecking luxuries of
the super rich tax collected from those
with money to burn could be used to
fight or mitigate the impact of
pollution and increasingly frequent and
intense natural disasters still some
warn that focusing on the ultra wealthy
shouldn't absolve everyone else of
personal responsibility when you start
adding up all of the SUVs and all of the
number of trips to store and back where
you could just as easily walk it or take
public transport the fact is we're doing
way more damage than they are with their
private jets and gaviola Global News
Toronto
New Brunswick has won now Saskatchewan
has a policy on gender pronouns in
schools if a child or teen under 16
wants to change their preferred name or
pronoun they'll need their parents
permission an lgbtq2 plus group in
Regina calls that unconstitutional and
is taking legal action against the
province as tariya Israel reports
Advocates worry rules like this will put
students in danger
students across Canada are returning to
the classroom but there are new and
polarizing policies at schools in New
Brunswick and Saskatchewan setting off
protests
and fears for Trans students when we
think about the reasons that kids might
not want to tell their parents or or be
comfortable without being disclosed to
their parents
um it's often because they don't have a
supportive family at home in
Saskatchewan any student under 16 who
wants to identify by a different name or
pronoun now needs parental consent we
have the opportunity to look at a policy
that is going to bring families closer
together in this respect in their
education we need to look at that and
look at that seriously and you're seeing
other governments Across the Nation do
the same New Brunswick's conservative
Premier Blaine Higgs was the first to
introduce similar legislation while
other provinces like Manitoba and
Ontario are not ruling it out parents
you know must be fully involved and
fully aware what's happening the life of
their children
but trans people say they're being used
to score political points and that these
types of policies will only endanger
Teenagers by outing them I have some
really wonderful Library volunteers
helping me out Tara sipnyevsky founded
the trans-library in Ottawa last year I
grew up in a very transphobic time right
and I knew who I was at 14. I knew
exactly who I was at that age most of
the visitors who walk through her doors
are teenagers we like to keep these
because this is like a history of where
we've been
she worries pronoun policies will
alienate students who are already
vulnerable
a recent report from the University of
Ottawa found trans adolescents are five
times more likely to be suicidal but
that risk goes down by 25 percent when
their preferred pronouns and identities
are used according to a study from U.S
based charity the Trevor Project they're
working it out you know that they're
definitely working it out and they need
help working it out sometimes
Global News Ottawa
Ready Set campaign coming up why
Manitoba's election could be historic
plus the BC catering company serving up
a delicious world record
as Russia's War drags on there has been
a major shake-up in the Ukrainian
government President Vladimir zielinski
has replaced his defense minister after
heading the ministry for more than 550
days of full-scale War Alexi reznikov
has been replaced with rustam omerov
zelenski says the ministry needs new
approaches and other formats of
interaction with both the military and
Society
in Manitoba the one-month countdown has
begun to the provincial election while
the rate doesn't drop until Tuesday
party leaders have been unofficially
campaigning for weeks the incumbent
Premier Heather Stephenson will try to
win a third government for the
progressive conservatives she faces
stiff competition from the ndp's wob
canoe our chief political correspondent
David Akin will be tracking this and
David this race could be historic indeed
Heather Stephenson became Premier
Manitoba when she won her party's
leadership contest in the fall of 2021
and now she is trying to become the
first woman in Manitoba's history to
lead her party to a win in a general
election her Chief opponent is new
democrat wab canoe if canoe wins he will
become the first First Nations person to
become a premier anywhere in Canada wow
Heather Stevenson's Progressive
conservatives have been behind in the
polls for most of her time as Premier
but that Gap narrowed in the last three
months having since coming into office
has been very clear
that she is supportive of the so-called
Freedom Convoy uh the anti-vaxx movement
and is very willing to stoke divisive
language when it comes to Ottawa and
Justin Trudeau I hear about WAP canoe
every day the vote is on October the 3rd
but campaigning has been underway since
late spring both the PCS and the NDP
expect tough fights in Winnipeg but also
in smaller centers like Brandon and
dolphin it's almost block by Block it's
almost going to be neighborhood by
neighborhood 300 500 votes difference in
in 10 different writings
um I think that's how tight this might
be this is canoe's second election as
leader of the NDP and while the PC is
under former Premier Brian pallister won
a majority four years ago can who was
credited with turning around NDP
fortunes and picking up eight seats the
NDP has been very specific in positing
wob as not a First Nations Premier but a
premier for all and of course if you
know Canadian politics no indigenous
person is going to win solely catering
to indigenous interests Stephenson will
be trying to follow pallisters
back-to-back majority wins with one of
her own the issues that matter to all
Canadians are
kind of just writ large at the core of
this campaign it's Healthcare post covid
it's cost of living it's crime and
safety which is a quite a surprisingly
big issue in Winnipeg crime has gotten
out of control it's related of course
with poverty
David what are the key Battlegrounds
you'll be watching
well let's look at how things turned out
four years ago in 2019 the NDP won the
handful of writings in the north of the
province and you can see the PC blue was
dominant pretty much everywhere else but
then we take a look at Winnipeg downtown
like most Urban cores in Canada
Progressive parties dominate NDP and
liberals then as we move out to the
suburbs and into the rural areas of the
province well that's where the PCS are
here's the big wild card I think in this
race how are those who voted liberal and
green four years ago going to vote this
time let me demonstrate this writing
right here is called McPhillips it's
north of Winnipeg McPhillips writing and
four years ago this was the closest race
in the province the PC candidate won by
88 votes 88 votes but the Liberals got
1500 votes the greens got 400 votes now
if those green voters and liberal voters
from four years ago swing to either of
these parties well that of course could
affect the outcome in McPhillips but
there are dozens of writings like
McPhillips in Winnipeg and that's why
liberal and green voters this time
around well they could determine the
overall election winner all right David
Aiken in Ottawa thanks David
25 years since the Swiss Air disaster
ahead I'll speak with the former Navy
Commander tasked with recovering remains
[Music]
25 years later We Gather here at the
edge of the sea to mark this difficult
milestone in the spirit of remembrance
recognition
and healing this ceremony in Nova Scotia
marks 25 years since the deadly crash of
Swiss Air flight 111 the passenger jet
plunged Into The Frigid Waters off
Peggy's Cove on September 2nd 1998
during a flight from New York to
Switzerland killing all 229 people on
board
Greg Akins is the former commander of a
Canadian Navy vessel that was tasked
with recovering debris and remains Greg
thank you so much for joining us my
pleasure Nathan so can you tell us more
about your work in the recovery Mission
and how did it affect you personally
sure so we got a sale and when it became
apparent that it was no longer a rescue
it was strictly a search and recovery
and I was assigned as the on-scene
commander for a very large operation uh
that established a big exclusion Zone
because it was still a criminal
investigation the aircraft had you know
valuables money gems Etc on it and we
didn't know the extent of the debris
field yet and so it's a very large
exclusion Zone that we had to Monitor
and maintain so to keep people out so we
had aircraft boats uh Navy Air Force
Coast Guard
RCMP I'm doing that and then playing the
flight recorder was was job one because
it has a very limited time that the
transponder works and actually one of
our submarines first found a boat where
it was and then our divers recovered it
just as it was running out of battery
and actually a pretty heroic effort
because they were also running out of
air so we brought the um the black box
of course that's not black at all it's
surprisingly came on board it's orange
and so that was a very important certain
part of it and then from there it was
recovering the human remains and
aircraft Parts as much as we could with
the Canadian and of course the American
divers came up I had a very large
American Salvage ship the USS grapple
I'm working for me as well so we would
recover
um the human parts our ship was the uh
at Sea morgue and we process all the
human remains there and then take them
ashore with our helicopter to Shear
water there where they were further
processed wow and I understand it was
just months after you had become the
fleet's youngest Commander that you were
ordered to lead what would eventually
become Canada's largest peacetime Marine
operation what do you remember about the
moment you got that order
it's kind of hard to understand you know
what you're going into you know an
airplane crash and you know what does
that mean and sure that you know all the
there was a lot of moving pieces like
great complexity because of course the
search part of it we had a number of
ships mapping in detail with these very
sensitive uh sonars the the sea floor to
look for any
um parts of the aircraft and it was a
much larger operation than I would have
imagined
um and of course it took a long time we
were out there for over three weeks for
our part and luckily
um you know through the effort of
everybody involved by the time our task
ended we had recovered remains from
every single person we've identified on
that flight so we really felt good about
that hoping that would bring us some
closure to the family I'm sure it did
how did your role in the mission shape
your career and your life
so
it was without any doubt the the most
challenging Mission I had ever on Chuck
as a captain of a ship and and after
that as well just in terms of the not
just the magnitude and complexity but
also the just a huge leadership
challenge because of what we were facing
and we had really no concept of what
PTSD was uh had no experience with it
was a long time before Afghanistan of
course the war there and so when I
started to uh have Sailors who were
deeply affected at feet you know I would
be compassionate and and let them go
ashore I think it happened to two of
them out there but I didn't really
understand these were people I had
tremendous respect for I knew well and
yet they couldn't carry on with their
duties as Sailors at Sea and so that was
the first indication that this was not a
normal operation and and of course it
was lasting impacts after that I imagine
the divers especially because they had
the most gruesome task but also
um you know the people in our ship were
you know processing The Remains and
stuff it was a very very challenging
time psychologically
personally I didn't know that I'd impact
me so severely until years later
I was just having increasing
psychological challenges I just didn't
understand
as PTSD and then finally I you know it
came to the point where it was affecting
me severely um with you know fastbacks
anxiety and depression that I went and
sought help and luckily the the Navy was
able to provide me with good resources
to help and I'm also fortunately a
Christian so my faith helped enormously
in that and that healing process
afterwards
25 years on how are you marking this day
so it's been a lot of prayer yesterday
and today just for the families and the
divers again in particular who just had
a a day in day out a horrific task that
they did incredibly well
and selflessly
that is retired Navy Commander Greg
Aikens Greg for everything you have
carried since your service for your
service itself and for joining us today
thank you very much it's my pleasure
[Music]
game-changing win next the Canadian
men's basketball team scores a ticket to
the Olympics
[Music]
it is one of the biggest days in
Canadian sporting history Canada has
stunned Spain the world's number one
basketball team to move on to the next
round of the FIBA World Cup more
importantly the men punched their ticket
to next Summer's Paris Olympics Eric
Sorensen explains how it all unfolded it
was win or go home for Canada and it
looked like the men's team was going to
let another big moment slip away when
Spain surged to a 12-point lead after
three quarters but this time would be
different Canada mounted a furious
comeback clutch shots from Dylan Brooks
who brought a toughness to this team
and Shea gilges Alexander who's emerged
as one of the true superstars in the
world of basketball and before you knew
it Canada had knocked off the defending
World Cup champions it was a lot of
adversity hats off to them but I think
our group just wanted a little bit more
oh you know it was at stake and we were
willing to do whatever it took the wind
not only puts Canada into the World Cup
quarterfinals but with losses by Brazil
and others this country has now
qualified for the Olympics next year we
want to make sure that everybody knows
that we're knocking at the door
and that we're thirsty for more a
Canadian team last made the Olympics
with Steve Nash in 2000 that and a new
era of pro basketball in this country
with Vince Carter and the Toronto
Raptors inspired a new generation that
is finally delivering on the promise
they've shown they did it they they
they're going to the Olympics it's it's
phenomenal it feels as though it's the
first step of of really
um an era of the men's program in Canada
will be in one of the best in the world
gilges Alexander's mother went to the
Olympics in track and field for him it
feels pretty special she holds no more
bragging rights and I know the best
athletes in the world are there
and we um consider ourselves amongst
that group and it's it's a good feeling
to go but first the Canadians will play
Luka doncic and Slovenia in the World
Cup quarterfinals on Wednesday Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
and that's global national for this
Sunday tonight's your candida may make
you hungry
[Applause]
Sheila's catering company pulled off
this enormous feat in White Rock BC the
board full of cured meat fruit and
cheese kept chilled with ice blankets
spans 148 meters crushing the old record
of 62 meters a falconer was even there
to help keep seagulls away thanks so
much for watching and see you tomorrow
have a great night
thank you
foreign